good morning John I love you ha ha oh ok
moving on we are now the 81st most
subscribed channel on YouTube and I
mention this only because 81st is a very
important number it marks as high as we
will go in the charts we are about to be
made 80 second by the most amazing Toby
Turner I get really excited with people
that I like a lot start patching us in
the subscription charts and after you
watch his literal Harry Potter trailer
you will know that he deserves 81st more
than we do wha-ha Catherine's family is
still in town we were having a whirlwind
of epic family adventures we only get to
see them about once a year so it's
important to back in the love so let's
look at some of that we went to Green
Oak Park which Catherine and I used to
live right across from and I really
loved the place and I like to throw rock
from Catherine likes to build stuff out
of rocks so it's good to know that at
least in some ways she has the female
instincts of let's build things together
and I have the male instincts of rock
star rock and Jessie my nephew saw his
very first real live deer here in
Greenock Park and I was very excited and
he was very excited and he wanted to go
hug it and I told him that when people
approached wild animals oftentimes they
get attacked and hurt very seriously and
it turned out that this was a little bit
too much information for him to handle
but it's true and then we went to see
Jessie's very first baseball game it was
a lot of firsts for him I think it's
really important that whenever you're
having a new experience is you start out
with kind of a subpar experience
otherwise you don't really have anywhere
to go from there
like your first apartment should be a
hole in the wall and the toilet should
be right next to the bed with no wall or
door between you that's how you should
start so that every time you get a new
apartment and there's there's a door
between your bed and the toilet like
that feels like a significant upgrade in
your life and those upgrades make you
really happy which is why I think it is
important for Jessie's first baseball
game to be the missoula Osprey who
happened to be the worst team in the
minor estava minor leagues
we didn't rally I'd go for the peanuts
to be totally honest then Jesse had to
go which is sad but also kind of a
relief because he's a little bit
high-maintenance that make me sound like
a Decepticon for saying that oh well it
didn't mean the Katherine's parents and
I could go on more longer excursions out
of town which we did to the National by
sunrise
hey Katherine yeah what are the
Buffalo say to his son when he went off
to college I don't know what did he say
bye son okay I walked up to this huge
pile of antlers which had been collected
over the years and then stuck down on to
a pole so that it looked as if there was
a huge pile of antlers and then I had a
hat on how I hit my head on it and there
were grasshoppers everywhere like plague
level every time you'd move they would
explode from the ground then I found out
some amazing information about bison who
look docile and slow and peaceful but
can run as fast as a horse and are
extremely aggressive this videotape is
owned by the US government so I can show
it to you and I don't have to worry
about copyright problems the guy was
fine but the point is clear never
approached wildlife and though at the
National Bison Range we saw bighorn
sheep and pronghorn antelope and a baby
mule deer and a lot more than that we
didn't get up close to very many bison
except for this dead stuffed one at the
visitors center but the dead stuffed
bison was pretty impressive very
beautiful and really a very amazing
animal that we almost drove into
extinction due to our ignorance in aah
nobody wants to see that then we went to
a restaurant outside of the National
Bison Range where they serve bison
burgers which I feel like is kind of
weird like you you got a taste the thing
that you just enjoyed looking at I don't
understand exactly why I think that's
weird like the animals aren't coming
from the Bison range they're like half
cow have bison and they're on ranges and
they can't be wild anyways and I just
realized that my wallet is made out of
Bisons mother so I'm going to shut up
now and that's oh I'll see you on Friday